the battle scars new maria pole are
still fresh in the city itself life is
slowly returning to normal but most
residents have doubts that the truce
will last what sees fun it's just a
performance as a political scientist
uncertain that this war will last five
to nine years certificates yes I'm for
breaking away that's my opinion I don't
care what others think that boobs are
lost on your thumbs ish there will be no
ceasefire because they have killed so
many of our brother brother for Diwali
so far the ceasefire in eastern Ukraine
has been holding with only a few
breaches reported blew the wing within
the past 24 hours rebel shelled anti
terrorist positions 28 times 10 of them
took place after the ceasefire was
announced romania volume kiev and the
kremlin-backed separatists have agreed
to swap prisoners soon and russia
sending another aid convoy to the
Donbass region ukrainian President Petro
poroshenko has it he is willing to make
more concessions we are ready to provide
the significant steps including the
decentralization of power including
their speciality under certain districts
of the Donetsk and Lugansk region for
the economic freedom guaranteed the
rights for use any languages on this
territory despite the truce the rebels
are still demanding independence from
ukraine